ah bonjour à tous d'ici quelques jours
on en saura plus sur les futurs produits
haut de gamme de huawei p20 p20 like peu
d'impro ils vont être présentés le 27
mars prochain à paris et d'ici là on a
déjà quelques rumeurs croustillantes à
se mettre sous la dent plein d'infos des
choses qui sont sensiblement avéré a
confirmé en tout cas c'est super
passionnant et ça on va le regarder
maintenant
le début d'année n'en finit pas après la
présentation du samsung
après la présentation des samsung galaxy
s 9 et s9 plus voici huawei qui va
dévoiler ses nouveaux grands modèles
flagship le 27 mars prochain à paris on
a déjà plein d'infos sur les p 20 p 20
propre et 20 lite vous ai déjà fait une
première vidéo d'ailleurs s'ils
voulaient d'abord elle est si une
première vidéo qui parle est
effectivement des tendances des
premières rumeurs pour ses produits mais
là on voit qu'il ya plein d'autres trucs
qui arrive et ça c'est juste dingue
alors qu'est ce qu'on va retrouver sur
cette paie 20 p 20 pro opéra lite avant
d'aller plus loin et avant de vous dire
tout ce que je sais et toutes les infos
que j'ai pu glaner à droite à gauche
j'ai déjà savoir ce que vous vous en
pensez est-ce que vous avez des infos
est-ce que tout de suite moment où
regarder cette vidéo vous savez à quoi
devrait ressembler pourrait ressembler
cp 20 p 20 pompes et 20 light mettez la
pause marquée mais sans commentaire et
on reprend tout de suite allez c'est
parti
mettez la pause voilà normalement c'est
bon vous avez remis lecture sinon si
vous n'avez pas mis la pomme dorée
tricher bon c'est pas grave
l'épée 20 p20 pro ep20 light sont très
bientôt annoncé et on voit qu'on a un
triptyque qui sont super intéressant
parce que on a d'un côté p20 like qui va
être le produit d'entrée de gamme de la
gamme p 20 le p 20 le moyen de gamme
dans le haut de gamme toujours bien
évidemment dans le haut de gamme et le
pépin pro comme son nom l indique le
modèle professionnel qui me permet
d'aller plus loin en termes de photos et
de vidéos surtout côté design entre à
trouver des grands smartphones des
grands écrans et surtout une encoche
notch qu'on a déjà vu je ne sait plus
sur quel modèle de la fin 2017 qui était
énormément pompey on retrouve
effectivement le design en tout cas de
l'iphone 10 ce design a été énormément
décrié et pourtant beaucoup de
constructeurs ce matin de pomper c'est
plutôt un bon signe pour apple ça veut
dire que dans l'absolu même s'ils sont
critiqués ils sont pas vraiment trompé
et que ce sera une caméra trop d'aix
avec un scan en trois dimensions de
votre visage pour l'instant j'en sais
pas plus toujours est il qu'on devrait
retrouver les capteur d'empreintes
digitales à l'arrière cour pénale a été
à l'avant pour le paiement pro et pour
le p 20 un design vous le dis toujours
grand écran avec une petite bordure en
bas sur le pv light en bas vous aurez la
marque huawei qui sera inscrite et sur
le p 20 lp d'impro vous devrez
retrouvez le capteur d'empreintes
digitales qui se situera juste en
dessous de votre écran un écran bien
évidemment bord à bord et surtout de
nouvelles couleurs et des couleurs
dégradé on devait avoir un noir et un
bleu uni un dégradé de violet bleu vert
ou rose doré on va avoir des produits
qui vont avoir une tronche un petit peu
différente par rapport aux autres
produits de la gamme mais effectivement
on voit très bien que pour voir où et
l'idée c'est d'aller plus loin de faire
un pas en avant on passe du pdis au p 20
directement c'est un bon vin futur pour
voir où et l'idée d'un point de vue
marketing
c'est effectivement de brûler les étapes
et d'avoir le produit le plus innovant
le photophone de l'année alors est-ce
qu'ils vont y arriver
est-ce qu'ils ont détrôné samsung avec
son galaxy s 9 et s9 plus ça reste à
voir
on va faire un petit tour du côté de la
fiche technique bien évidemment comme
d'habitude j'ai tout noter ici je vais
pas vous l'affiché parce que ce serait
hyper pénible mais je vous explique un
petit peu les vraies différences entre
le p 20 p 20 propre et un light du côté
de l'écran je sois tu paies 20 août les
vents prendre à trouver un format 19/9
2240 par 1080 un écran 5,7 pouces lcd
pour le p 20 un écran 6 pouces oled pour
le pépin pro pour pétain light aurait
trouvé un écran 15.6 pouces lcd
le design est assez sympa je vous
l'expliqué avec la petite encoche à
l'avant les caméras à la verticale de
l'autre côté qui sont positionnées sur
le côté gauche du smartphone un design
avec de nouvelles couleurs quelque chose
qui va effectivement se démarquer de la
concurrence et qui peut être assez
séduisant côté puissance on doit trouver
sur le pays 20 ep20 pro le kirin 970 le
processeur de huawei qui est dopée à
l'intelligence artificielle pour le père
un light on a trouvé un kirin 659 pour
le p 26 giga de ram pour p 20 produits
giga de ram et pour le pv litetouch giga
de ram normalement de ravoir 64 giga de
stockage sans pépin light sur le père un
pro et sur le p 20 probablement un peu
plus on l imagine après sur le p 20 et
le pev impro parce qu'a priori il n'y
aurait pas d'emplacement pour mettre une
carte micro sd vous avez l'emplacement
pour mettre une double carte sim mais
pas de micro sd donc ce sera pas
possible d'augmenter la mémoire
donc on peut très bien imaginer pourquoi
pas envie d'avoir 64 giga d'arriver
directement à 128 giga de stockage voire
256 ça paraît pas déconner elles sont le
fait d'un pro 512 pourquoi pas sur le
paiement à l'acte faudra trouver du 64
giga avec la par contre la possibilité
de rajouter une carte micro sd et du
coup pas double carte sim lille tournon
évidemment sous un androïde 8.0 oreo le
pedn ac devrait avoir entre nous tous
4.2 on devrait avoir normalement sur les
autres modèles bluetooth 5.0 on imagine
très bien certification ip68 sur les
trois modèles et un tarif à 679 euros
pour le p 20 899 euros pour le pépin pro
et 369 euros pour le pays 20 light alors
je vous ai pas parlé d'un petit détail
qui à mon avis est plus important sur
ses smartphones
c'est l'appareil photo pour le perdant
devra avoir une double caméra de saïfi
une 16 mégapixels et une 24 mégapixels
avec une ouverture potentiellement f 1.9
voir f 1.6 à l'arrière également double
objectif
on peut très bien imaginer avoir la même
une 16 mégapixels et une 24 mégapixels
avec une ouverture de f 1.6 pour voir
quelque chose de très lumineux mais là
où ça devient vraiment très intéressant
c'est du côté du p 20 euros
le pépin pro aura pas seulement une
caméra à l'arrière pas deux caméras
l'arrière mesdames et messieurs mais
bien trois caméras à l'arrière c'est la
surenchère on imagine qu'il ya un réel
intérêt derrière compass vous coller
trois caméras pour dire mais autant dont
deux mois je vous en ai 3 6 mois qui en
est le plus donc c'est moi qui est
l'appareil le plus performant non on
avait un vrai sens saxo et 3 cumulé vous
arriverez à 40 mégapixels je voudrais y
avoir un capteur classique avec une
ouverture de f 1.6 donc très lumineux un
autre nuno crom on peut très bien
imaginer aussi en f1 points 6 et un
téléobjectif avec un zoom optique x 300
f 2.4 ça vous permettra d'avoir une
image qui sera vraiment magnifique on
faible luminosité d'avoir quelque chose
avec un bon rendu avec un zoom optique
également est vraiment un appareil photo
complètement optimisé
on imagine que ça derrière avec un kirin
970 mousse et à l'intelligence
artificielle avec la reconnaissance de
scène
vous allez avoir des photos qui vont
être totalement optimisé et des choses
qui sont vraiment magnifiques
d'autant plus que huawei travaille en
partenariat avec les cas les cas qu'est
vraiment connue pour sa qualité du point
de vue des photos et d'ailleurs sur les
photos qui ont été récupérées ci et là
sur internet on voit la mention
d'ailleurs je voulais lire les cas vario
summilux 27 80 f en point 62.4 à spa
voit très bien que l'idée de smartphones
du pays un pro c'est pas seulement
d'avoir un smartphone c'est d'abord un
appareil photo de qualité
professionnelle dans votre smartphone et
c'est tout l'intérêt de ces produits
d'ailleurs ce qu'on a vu il ya pas très
longtemps avec samsung galaxy s 9 et s9
plus l'idée
de plus avoir juste un smartphone avec
une bonne caméra mais d'abord un
appareil photo de qualité semi-pro dans
votre smartphone pour le bénin live sera
pas exactement la même chose vous aurez
effectivement un double capteur à
l'arrière 16 mégapixels et 2 mégapixels
toujours un partenariat avec l'état et à
l'avant une seule caméra de celle fille
en 16 mégapixels j'ai pas d'info sur
l'ouverture mais on imagine très bien
qu'on pourra voir une ouverture de f
1.9 sans aucun problème d'un côté et de
l'autre de l'appareil alors maintenant
il n'ya pas une question qui se pose
voit très bien que vous voyez c'est le
troisième mondial apple samsung wave
samsung samsung apple des fois sa terre
change un peu la place de leader mais en
règle générale c'est apple samsung wave
est ce qui est super intéressant là
dedans c'est de se dire quelle stratégie
va mettre en place
huawei pour contrer les autres et pour
gagner du terrain ce qu'on voit très
clairement c'est que d'un point de vue
design on s'inspire un petit peu de
apple et de sa caméra trop d'eps et deux
sont encore forcément si on veut des
grands écrans est un format 19/9 il faut
pouvoir gagner du terrain et on peut pas
forcément lever la caméra et le haut
parleur à l'avant donc on fait la petite
encoche bon pourquoi pas le format 19/9
je suis pas sûr que ce soit le meilleur
pour regarder des vidéos et des photos
parce que on va forcément à les renier
dans l'image après tout pourquoi pas
sera mais d'avoir effectivement quelque
chose d'un peu plus grand ça peut être
sympa maintenant du point de vue de la
photo on voit qu'ils vont vraiment en
concurrence frontale avec samsung
samsung et sa galaxy ace 9,9 plus on
était vraiment loin cette année avec une
ouverture variable de f 2.4 et f
1.5 là on aura pas d'ouverture variables
très clairement mais par contre on aura
ces trois objectifs et derrière une
machine qui sera capable d'optimiser
votre photo et votre vidéo complètement
par rapport aux trois objectifs faire de
choisir la meilleure solution à un
instant t
avec une puissance de calcul derrière
est le processeur le keirin 170 donc
vraiment avoir un truc qui devrait être
vraie bête de course une vraie bête de
compet maintenant à savoir si cette
gamme de paix vin va réussir à s'imposer
et à prendre un petit peu le lead par
rapport à samsung et par rapport à apple
c'est en tout cas tout l'intérêt
stratégique pour eux dites moi vous ce
que vous en pensez est ce que ces pépins
paix vappereau ep20 là il pourrait vous
intéresser est-ce que vous pensez que
cette gamme vraiment qu'ils peuvent
venir révolutionner et continuer à faire
progresser ses gammes de photophones
convard qu'on a déjà pu trouver les
années précédentes et que maintenant on
retrouve en voir plus fort en 2010
est ce qu'à votre avis p20 pro pourra
mettre une grande claque au samsung
galaxy s 9 et s9 plus est ce que vous
pensez que huawei va dans le bon sens
mais en place les bonnes innovations les
bons produits qu'elle marque vous
préférez entre apple samsung et huawei
alors l'idée ce n'est pas de faire une
confrontation frontale parce que ça
n'aurait pas d'intérêt parce que chaque
marque a ses spécificités
chaque marque a ses propres intérêts et
chaque marque est vraiment bonne chacune
dans son domaine mais on voit qu'elle
est de manioc effectivement la
concurrence fait rage
et là on voit qu'on est très clairement
en train de se battre pour être le
photophone de l'année 2018
mark et moi tous ces commentaires
viennent évidemment comme d'habitude
vous invite à me laisser des jolies
pouces on reste connectés parce que il
ya énormément de choses à dire dessus
c'est un sujet qui est hyper passionnant
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner parce que
d'ici quelques temps on va beaucoup
parler de cp 20 p 20 points ont été
vains light va y avoir énormément de
choses à dire on a aussi beaucoup
reparlé des samsung galaxy s 9 et s9
plus on va essayer de démêler tout ça
pour savoir quel est le photophone de
l'année 2018 alors rassurez-vous 2018 ne
fait que commencer
va y avoir plein d'autres choses qui
vont arriver mais en tout cas tout de
suite on vraiment les grandes tendances
ça m'étonnerait que samsung vous sortent
un autre photophone cette année huawei
je ne pense pas non plus apple on attend
leur réponse d'ici le mois de septembre
2018 donc rester connectée va y avoir
plein de choses super intéressant à voir
ensemble d'ici là un véritable essai des
jolies pouces vous abonner vos
commentaires tout ça tout ça plein
d'amour partout n'oubliez pas vous êtes
les meilleurs vous embrasse et à bientôt
ciao
[Musique]